veteran reporter Bob Woodward is the
associate editor at The Washington Post
he joins us from Washington now Bob good
morning so much the disguise now you
have independently confirmed the New
York Times reporting that White House
officials were involved in talking with
this with congressman Nunez what can you
tell us about the documents that they
saw and what what is the significance of
those documents
well the people I've talked to who have
met with President Trump on this said
that there were 35 to 40 reports where
names of people associated with Trump or
identifying characteristics were
revealed which shouldn't happen now how
serious this is is unclear one of the
people who met with President Trump this
week said it's kind of a cast of clowns
because you have a situation where the
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee goes to the White House gets
information then goes up to Congress and
his a press conference and says oh look
what I've learned and then runs down to
the White House to brief President Trump
what the Chairman learned from people in
the National Security Council so there's
something weird or at least
uncoordinated going on here Bob other
than that what question does it arise
from you well the Russian investigation
is really serious the the clearly
Vladimir Putin and the Russians launched
a espionage operation a covert operation
to affect the election interestingly
enough it's something our CIA does
frequently abroad in a secret way but
this election was so close that really
got to get to the bottom of it the
design of a counterintelligence
operation here is to stop the Russians
from doing that
and not being able to do it in the
future whether they're crimes involved
here the question then becomes were
Trump associates or people involved in
coordinating way and that's what the FBI
is looking at but when we talk about the
gravity of the situation at hand and
yesterday's Senate Intelligence
Committee hearings mark warner the
senator spoke about a misinformation
campaign spreading fake news and up to
fit I think several key states during
the election we're talking about 15,000
operatives who may have been involved in
a broader campaign of misinformation do
you think the public is aware enough
about what may have happened and that
there is a sufficient amount of alarm in
terms of these investigations well I
think the Senate investigation is very
serious there they're working together
at this point they're making that
bipartisan I don't think there's enough
awareness of this this this is a big
deal but it's it's a big deal from the
point of view of how do you stop it how
do you get it out in the open so we can
have free elections where the process is
untampered with by the russians or
others Bob what do you think Glenn might
have to say about this that might
contribute to our understanding well he
key player I know Flynn a little bit
talked to him in January and he insists
that the whole approach by President
Trump in Russia is kind of a two-track
strategy reach out to Putin but also
doing some very tough things with our
military that Putin is going to hate so
the real policy here is yet to emerge
that's that's part of this story I mean
the difficulty here is there is a
context of a lot of hysteria a lot of
overreaching I think on both sides and
as the old former editor
The Washington Post Ben Bradlee used to
say slow down
the truth emerges in the Internet age
with all the tweets and so forth that's
very difficult well talking about the
truth emerging in Nora's interview with
Paul Ryan he was a term whistleblower as
a to describe the source involved what
do you make of the use of that word in
this circumstance given what you know
yeah I don't think it's the case this is
somebody on the National Security
Council staff my paper is reported and
confirmed and expanded on what the New
York Times said here it's a very strange
idea as I said that you would get an
information from the White House and
then have to go down and brief the
president not the president presumably
can call anyone on his staff in and say
what's going on what does the
administration have a narrative to tell
based on these recent things that
chairman no Nunez talked about to
explain the president's tweets I I
haven't seen it and that that's of
course what's gonna happen if you go
back to fumbled investigations like in
water gave where the White House and
President Nixon were covering up some
other times I think the White House and
other administration's has said oh
there's this investigation it's serious
business let's do our own inquiry and
get the facts out that's what President
Trump should do here unless the facts
are going to be extremely damaging but
transparency is always the answer get
out ahead of it whether that's going to
happen we will see all right Bob
Woodward thank you very much well to
leave it there I'm sure we'll talk to
you another time
thank you sir Thanks